un fleuron de l'histoire industrielle de
l'histoire économique et de l'histoire
sociale de la france
edouard philippe n'a pas ménagé ses
effets lors de la séance de questions au
gouvernement le premier ministre est
déterminé à préserver les sites de
renault en france
nous serons extrêmement attachés
intransigeant même je dirais à la
préservation du site france décès de
france renault est une entreprise
mondiale c'est vrai mais enfin ça marque
française est évidente et donc nous
serons extrêmement exigeant sur ce point
nous serons extrêmement exigeants sur le
fait que la france demeure le centre
mondial pour renault de l'ingénierie la
recherche de l'innovation du
développement
c'est quelque chose dont vous savez
d'ailleurs dans le département des
yvelines
c'est combien ces précieux pour préparer
l'avenir et pour garder une capacité à
préparer la cour le constructeur
automobile français envisage de fermer
quatre de ses sites
parmi eux flins dieppe choisy le roi ou
encore les fonderie de bretagne
selon le canard enchaîné le constructeur
automobile compte s'en séparer dans le
cadre d'un plan de 2 milliards d'euros
d'économies qui doit être dévoilé le 29
mai un groupe dont l'état est le premier
actionnaire
une intervention du gouvernement est
donc particulièrement attendu après
avoir beaucoup parlé de souveraineté
emmanuel macron va devoir passer aux
actes
le projet de délocalisation s'accélère
l'inquiétude grandit comment croire que
le gouvernement qui pourtant clame
souveraineté et réindustrialisation va
intervenir alors que macron vient de
céder à alstom alcatel technip lafarge
un futur incertain critiquée également
par philippe martinez le patron de la
cgt conteste la stratégie du groupe
automobile
mené ces dernières années quand on veut
réindustrialiser le pays
c'est impensable la situation de renault
n'est pas dû à la crise sanitaire
elle est due à des années de gouvernance
de carlos ghosn qui a été érigée comme
un dieu pendant des années et on voit
les conséquences de sa stratégie
c'est cette stratégie qu'il faut changer
est-ce que les 5 milliards que le
gouvernement s'apprête à prêter renault
vont servir à restructurer l'entreprise
c'est un gros problème la survie de
renault est un véritable enjeu pour
bercy ces fermetures et ses
restructurations
pour y entraîner une vague de
licenciements